hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be attempting to solve the single
biggest mystery in one piece the mystery
that was established on the very first
page of the manga what is the one piece
treasure the treasure of unimaginable
value that roger revealed to the world
right before his execution launching a
golden age of piracy the treasure that
joy boy left behind on the mysterious
island of laughtale and which made roger
and his crew laugh while crying tears of
joy the treasure from which the very
title of our story is derived and yet we
still don't know what it actually is
is it gold and silver is it secret
information is it weapons is it the all
blue is it the power of friendship is it
all of the above there are so many
theories out there but i finally have my
own a theory that could be the craziest
one you've ever heard so let's get into
it you guys know the drill if you enjoy
our one piece content leave a quick like
and subscribe it really helps me out a
lot
and of course this video will contain
one piece manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned now i've seen a lot of great
theories about the one piece treasure
and in general it is a super interesting
topic that has been debated for over 25
years
my approach to tackling this mystery is
to examine the narrative structure of
the story itself and to determine what
the treasure needs to be in order to
make the story flow towards a satisfying
conclusion so i will not be relying on
speculation about extremely specific
meanings or symbols such as for example
looking at the numbers of chapters and
the potential japanese word play on
these numbers and how that word play
relates to what happens in the chapters
themselves don't get me wrong there are
excellent videos on youtube that do
exactly that including videos by o'hara
and the japanese youtuber uderon but i
just personally prefer to look at the
more general picture and what i think
the story structure and narrative
require the one piece to be
also since we know that oda initially
thought that the one piece would be a
five year story and yet it just keeps
growing and growing i find it hard to
believe that he planned exactly which
specific events will be contained in
which specific chapters decades into the
future i could be wrong but i just know
from personal experience as someone
who's done a bit of writing that i
definitely wouldn't be able to do that
okay now let's go back to the beginning
the very first page of the very first
chapter of the one piece story when the
one piece treasure is first introduced
we are led to believe that this is a
vast material treasure left by the
pirate gold d roger also known as gold
roger basically a whole bunch of people
are convinced that if they find this
treasure they will become rich beyond
their wildest dreams and so the prospect
of finding the treasure launches a
golden age of piracy this event is based
on the final moments of real-life pirate
olivier levasseur who right before he
was hanged back in 1730 told the crowd
who had gathered to watch his execution
that he left a great treasure somewhere
in the world according to legend
levasseur wore a necklace that contained
a cryptogram of 17 lines and he
proclaimed that whoever deciphers the
cryptogram will be able to find his
treasure he then threw the necklace into
the crowd right before he was executed
for nearly 300 years after his death
treasure hunters have been searching for
lava sir's treasure and some are
continuing the search to this very day
and having drawn from this epic
historical event the first page of the
one piece manga is arguably the best
first page of any manga in history it is
brilliant because it sets up such a
tantalizing mystery and such an epic
quest from the very beginning and since
we know that real-life pirates were
driven primarily by the desire to enrich
themselves this idea of an unimaginable
material treasure out there for the
taking is certainly interesting enough
to keep us reading at this early stage
of the story who doesn't like a great
mystery more money than they can ever
dream of and a grand adventure all at
the same time but as the one piece story
has progressed the idea that this
treasure that we have been searching for
for 25 years is just a bunch of gold and
jewels became less and less appealing
after learning everything that we know
now about the void century the ancient
kingdom the world government the
poneglyphs and joy boy if the one piece
turned out to be just a bunch of
material wealth like gold and silver
everyone would be pretty disappointed
well everyone except for maybe nami the
one-piece treasure will certainly be
extremely valuable but at this point it
must be more than just gold coins and
shiny jewels it has to somehow reveal
the mystery of the void century and the
ancient kingdom it has to tell the story
of joy boy the man who actually left the
treasure there in the first place and
most importantly it must serve a
significant purpose in the overall story
up to this point the treasure itself
hasn't really played a central role it's
just been a mysterious concept in the
background of the story luffy certainly
didn't need help from this treasure to
get as far as he has so does he even
need the treasure at all in order for
the one piece to fit smoothly into the
story it will have to play some sort of
real and active role in the final arcs
it seems to me that the true nature of
the one piece treasure will depend
heavily on when it is actually revealed
in the story will it be revealed that
the very end after the final battle has
already concluded making its reveal a
sort of
script or epilogue or will it be
revealed before the final battle meaning
that it's going to be something that can
actually be used in the battle itself if
the treasure is something that is
revealed at the very end after all the
major conflicts have ended then it could
be something more symbolic such as the
entire world joining together to create
one whole the entire world being in one
piece also totally not mark and arter
the library of ahara have made
exceptional videos regarding the theory
that the one piece treasure could
actually be sake they both point to the
importance of the famous song bink's
sake which has been around for centuries
they argue that the lyrics of being sake
could actually tell the tragic story of
the void century a story which has been
erased from history by the world
government but which has been secretly
passed on as an unassuming sea shanty
from generation to generation i actually
completely agree with this
interpretation of bing's socket the
connection to laugh tale at the very end
of the song is a dead giveaway that this
song holds important symbolic meaning
about the void century and joy boy and
yes it is possible that the song
includes important clues about the void
century the dawn of the world and even
the one piece treasure itself building
off of this totally not mark and our
tour along with others of course have
proposed that sake itself may be the one
piece treasure in his video artur did an
amazing job of pointing out how sake has
been present in the story from the very
beginning from the very first chapter
and the very first volume cover and how
it has continued to play an important
role in the story as a symbol of
friendship brotherhood and celebration
both videos are truly excellent and i
don't want to understate that and i will
link both videos in the description so
definitely check them out however as i
implied earlier the one piece treasure
being sake would make sense if the
treasure is only revealed after the
final battle and then the sake could be
used to cement the bond that all of our
heroes have formed along their epic
journey the sake would then usher in a
giant party and celebration the likes of
which the world has never seen before
but sake itself is not likely to play a
key role in actually winning the final
battle not unless soda turned suck into
an overpowered logia devil fruit or
something in chapter
576 whitebeard declares in front of
everyone that the one piece is indeed
real and he says that when it is found a
grand battle will engulf the world and
the whole world will be shaken to its
core to me this strongly implies that
the one piece will be found before this
grand battle and that it will play a
role in shaking the world to its core in
turning the world upside down and in
bringing about a new era a new dawn this
is why i believe that the one piece
treasure won't just be something that is
revealed at the very end rather it will
be something that will be used in the
final battle itself and this distinction
has a profound impact on our conception
of what the one piece could be there are
two important things to consider before
i make my big reveal about what i think
the one piece has to be we have to
remember that everything written on the
poneglyphs has to be considered very
important because the ancient people who
created them went out of their way to
preserve these monuments
and the space that they had for writing
things upon these monuments was limited
so it goes without saying that the
information that these ancient people
chose to preserve on the poneglyphs was
extremely important in fact this
information is likely crucial for
eventually defeating the world
government and ushering in the dawn of
the world so the fact that three ancient
weapons are mentioned in detail on the
ponoglyphs means that these weapons will
be indispensable for the final battle
poseidon pluton and uranus are not just
cool ancient weapons they are actual
requirements for defeating the world
government and liberating the world you
absolutely need these weapons in order
to usher in the dawn of the world and
that is why roger knew that he was too
early poseidon had not yet reappeared
and so roger would have to pass the
torch to the next generation and as we
know now that next generation would not
only feature the return of poseidon but
also of joy boy in the form of luffy i
made a whole video arguing that joy boy
aka sun god nika is actually the ancient
weapon uranus and i will link that video
in the description below i mention this
now because i believe that all three
ancient weapons are critical for
deciphering the true nature of the one
piece and i will get back to them in a
little bit
after the ponoglyphs the second
important thing to consider is bellamy
the hyena more specifically let's think
back to what he said in chapter 224
during a conversation in which he argues
that the existence of a sky island is
just an empty pipe dream bellamy also
says the following the lost city of gold
the emerald city the great treasure of
one piece the fools who go looking for
their dream treasure cannot notice
what's right in front of them in this
era of the sea the ones who lack real
strength are the ones who are killed by
their own imaginations so yeah bellamy
says all of this and yet in the very
next arc of the story two of these
so-called pipe dreams are confirmed to
really exist one is the sky island
itself skypia and the other is the lost
city of gold shandora which is located
on sky bia so what about the other two
pipe dreams the emerald city and the one
piece treasure as i established earlier
the one piece is not just going to be
gold and silver because that would no
longer make sense from a narrative
perspective and yet roger is no liar so
when he used great material wealth to
entice a bunch of pirates to look for
the one piece it's because material
wealth is likely one aspect of the
treasure itself we also know that the
one piece treasure must reveal important
hidden information about the void
century and the conflict between the
ancient kingdom and the world government
and yet the treasure cannot be just
information alone because in that case
we would lose that aspect about material
wealth and if we take the words of
whitebeard seriously not only is the one
piece real but this treasure must also
have the power to shake the world to its
core material wealth and information
alone cannot necessarily do that at
least not in the literal sense but
something like an ancient weapon
certainly can thanks to the pornoglyphs
we know that the ancient weapons are
indispensable for bringing about the
dawn of the world but how can the one
piece be all of these things at once how
can the one piece treasure be a vast
material treasure of immeasurable value
a wellspring of ancient secret
information and a weapon that can defeat
the world government through my research
into the true nature of this treasure
i've come to believe that the one piece
can only be one thing an entire city
that has been lost to time
a lost city could contain massive
amounts of material wealth like silver
gold and jewels it could contain secret
forbidden knowledge within its books and
libraries or written on the walls of the
buildings themselves and it can also
contain an ancient weapon or weapons
that when activated could be used to
shake the world to its core and win the
final battle of the story just like the
sky island was not a fairy tale and just
like the golden city was not a fairy
tale but a real place located atop the
sky island
the emerald city that bellamy mentioned
could also be real and the one piece may
be within
this emerald city or it could be the
emerald city itself
after all out of the four things that
bellamy mentions the sky island the
golden city the emerald city and the one
piece we know that three are absolutely
real so why would the emerald city alone
be an exception the emerald city could
be laugh tale itself or it could be
located on love tale although the way i
picture it the city spans the length of
the entire island so the two are
basically synonymous with each other on
top of that i believe the lavtail itself
may also be an ancient weapon
more specifically the legendary
battleship pluton maybe the reason why
laughtale is so hard to find is because
it is a floating island something that
has been shown to exist in the world of
one piece and not only is it a floating
island but it is a floating island
battleship that can be used as the
ultimate weapon against the world
government and of course we know that
pluton has to be a battleship because
blueprints for it actually exist but
what we don't know is that this
battleship is the size of an entire
island it is even possible that this
island battleship may have the ability
to dive underwater which would go hand
in hand with the many theories which
state that laugh tale is actually
underwater this would also explain why
roger shanks and the prominent members
of their crews don't seem to have eaten
devil fruits if laughtale is hiding
underwater then you may need the ability
to swim in order to get to it and of
course being a devil fruit user would
drastically reduce your chances of
getting there but of course if you have
the right nakama by your side they may
be able to venture to laugh tail and
raise the island battleship to the
surface for you meaning that luffy robin
chopper and brook will still be able to
step on the island eventually the other
straw hats and their allies will just
need to get there first and raise the
island back up to the surface
so even though roger had gone to
laughtale he could not yet use it to
defeat the world government and this is
directly related to the fact that
shirahoshi luffy and potentially vivi
were not yet born shirahoshi is of
course poseidon luffy is joy boy and as
i have argued also uranus and vivi as
the heir of the nefertari family could
be the only one capable of activating
pluton which is something that i also
talked about in that joyboy is an
ancient weapon video the way i see it
all three ancient weapons must work
together to form one ultimate weapon
that is capable of defeating the world
government interestingly enough at the
end of episode 126 of the one-piece
anime we see king cobra of alabasta
standing in front of three symbols that
are written in the style of ancient
hieroglyphics these symbols include a
boat a sea king
and the sun in other words a warship a
force that can command the sea kings and
the sun god nika pluton poseidon uranus
poseidon may be required either to raise
laughtale aka pluton from the depths of
the ocean or to guide it into a position
where it can attack the world government
joyboy aka uranus may also be required
to serve as the leader of the
anti-government forces and to inspire
them with the drums of liberation and
vivi as a nefertari may be required to
activate and or pilot pluton also known
as the great island battleship laugh
tale so the three ancient weapons come
together to form one ultimate weapon the
one piece that is required to defeat the
world government and bring about the
dawn of the world
this ultimate weapon will be powerful
enough to destroy the red line and
create the all blue turning a world that
up until now had been split into four
pieces into one single piece
and of course this would fulfill
shirley's prophecy of luffy destroying
fishman island but he would only destroy
it after the fish men are evacuated up
to the surface using the noaa and so
according to this theory the one-piece
treasure really does have it all it has
material wealth it has secret forbidden
knowledge ancient weapons the power of
friendship and fate bringing everyone
together in the right place at the right
time and even the all blue it is all
connected and i personally would love to
see something like this happen because
just imagine that final battle imagine
luffy and the straw hats pulling up to
the red line on a massive island-sized
battleship flanked by sea kings on all
sides everyone is there the straw hat
grand fleet zunesha the revolutionary
army the world government gives it their
all imusama's secrets are unraveled the
national treasure of marijuana is
revealed and in the ensuing battle the
world is shaken to its core the red line
is destroyed the world government is
defeated and as the sun rises on a new
dawn of the world it reveals the all
blue and then of course everyone
celebrates with lots of socket
let me know what you guys think about
this theory and feel free to share all
your favorite theories down in the
comments below one thing i didn't
mention in this video but something that
could play a major role in the final arc
is the island of god valley and some
have pointed out that god valley
resembles the emerald city from the
wizard of oz in its structure we know
that god valley mysteriously vanished
from the face of the earth 38 years ago
so could god valley and laugh tale be
one and the same or could god valley be
a direct stepping stone to laugh tale i
could totally see roger laughing when he
realizes that the laugh tale that he's
been searching for for years was
actually a place that he already visited
over a decade earlier anyway don't
forget to leave your thoughts down in
the comments below i always love hearing
from you if you're looking for a video
to watch next i recommend my video about
joy boy being an ancient weapon link in
the description if you want to see more
one piece content in the future don't
forget to leave a like it helps me out a
lot and of course don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
subscribing is a completely free but
very important way of directly
supporting the channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see us peace cowboys